Speaker 1: Let's go next to LJ from Las Vegas.
LJ, what's going on in Vegas these days?
Speaker 5: I'm a very close race with Adam Laxalt
and basically the worst Democratic, you know,
candidate that can ever exist. But, you know.
Speaker 1: We will be watching that
one very closely on election night.
Speaker 5: Yeah, it's the sad fact that people
always like to complain about like, you know, the
candidates that are available during the picture
in the general election. While I'm screaming here,
it's like that's why we have primaries and why we
should go vote during primaries, which is the
important time indeed, other than the actual
general. But that's neither here nor there.
Speaker 1: What's on your mind today?
Speaker 5: I was actually wondering regarding
the messaging that we have regarding taxing
and just like how this, you know, taxation is
best. So, you know, I used to be a person of
the right. I grew up my entire life, a person of
the right. And as I've gotten older and I've got
access to more information and more points of
views, yes, I've learned, you know, that there
are some things that I do believe I should stay
conservative on. But when it comes to taxation,
I feel like the messaging that we have here in
the United States is all wrong. Right. And I've
been watching Jon Stewart's videos on it. So
if you have a chance or really good luck still.
Yes. And so I think the messaging that
we have in the here in the U.S. is that,
you know, like when we're being taxed,
it's money that's being taken away from
us rather than money that's being invested
towards us. Yeah. Right. That's for sure.
And I really do think that when you have those
conversations where I was watching your debate
coverage the other day where I forgot I think it
was in Georgia with. God, I can't remember the
candidate that was that. Well, Georgia was.
Speaker 1: Herschel Walker and Raphael
Warnock. Oh, no.
Speaker 5: I'm sorry.
Speaker 1: Or was it Brian Kemp and Stacey Abrams?
Speaker 5: Yes, yes, yes, yes. I had the
Libertarian candidate on there. Yeah. And he
kept screaming over and over again. It's like,
why don't you let the American people decide why
you let the American people decide? And I think
that messaging works because it's it's saying
a line, of course. Right. But the truth of the
matter is, is when they say let the American
people decide, they say, well, we want one
person from one corporation to decide everything
because that's what benefits us most financially.
Right. So when they say let the American people
decide and they say, you know what, the private
industry should decide this because they're
the ones who can make the best decision. Yeah,
I feel like they're saying no or removing the
option from the government who is voted on by the
American people. It's like you can't go up to your
boss and tell him. It's like, I want 1,000% raise
versus, you know, being able to
vote in primaries and elections
for someone who might give you benefits or you.
Speaker 1: So. LJ did you have a question today?
Speaker 5: I'm sorry. My question is, is do you
think that is that the correct messaging? So like
that was kind of like where I was going for here.
Speaker 1: Is the message that makes the most
sense to me and I'm not a focus group guy.
So this may not be messaging that works,
but it's messaging that makes sense to me. And we
go, listen, all this talk about taxes or slavery
and all this different stuff, you guys got to
grow up, okay? If humans are going to live in
groups that need to organize anything with more
than 150 people, sociology and anthropology and
group psychology, tell us you need to delegate
certain decision making. You need to delegate
certain powers. You need to centralize decision
making and powers, because otherwise you're
basically limited to groups of 150 people. These
ideas that a million people in a city are going
to just kind of like naturally organize in the
way that these libertarians talk about it just
does not work. There is no science that tells
us that that works in any discipline. So once
you understand and concede that what we need to do
is to have a system of voting that will make the
elected officials to whom we delegate power most
accurately representative of what the voters want.
And part of this includes that, yes, we need to,
in a society centralize the collection of taxes in
order to do big projects that just can't be done
by an individual or unilaterally done by a couple
of competing companies who just sort of fight it
out. And it's like, we just got to be adults. I,
I can't think of any other way to explain it.
Speaker 5: Right? No, I completely agree because
with my libertarian couple libertarian friends who
are who still lean left, they're not like complete
like idiots when it comes to taxation. Yeah,
we all have the same conversation point that
we come back to is like taxes are, you know,
incorrectly used like the war in Iraq. Sure.
Because they're given to billionaires
who don't need it or two companies who
are doing extremely well still receive
tax cuts. Right. So. Or how the oil
companies are, you know, in the corner? Yeah.
Speaker 1: There's a ton of examples of it,
but that's generally my take on how I would
talk about taxes. All right, my friend,
I got to let you go. Okay.
Speaker 5: Thank you, Jason.
Speaker 1: There's LJ from Vegas. Let's take a
quick break. If you're holding. Don't hang up
because we're going right back and we'll
hear from more people in just a moment.